is the message saying this app has been
such a game changer to me I've never
been so consistent with my Quran reading
before I knew about quranly you can get
quranly absolutely free no credit cards
for seven day free trial what are you
waiting for download it now brown
sisters and build a habit with the
qurani app right now
to your brothers and sisters
for the most trust or Praises glory and
gratitude belong to him now as you guys
know there was a video circulating where
Surah baqarah of Mishary was being
played with some kind of a spell or some
kind of a voice in the background
alhamdulillah that video actually the
whole channel from the mistaken got
taken down with the collective help with
of every single one of you guys now this
shows us that if we come together
collectively subhanallah towards a um to
avert harm we can subhanallah and that's
exactly what Allah says Let The Rise
amongst you a group of people who enjoy
good and forbid evil here we forbidden
Evil by mustly reporting that channel
that video and it got taken down
alhamdulillah so no one else has to
listen to that God knows what he was
saying in the background alhamdulillah
however also Allah talks about enjoying
good so with none of forbidden evil but
in joining good health brothers and
sisters this is where I need your
specific help I'm trying to raise 500
000 meals guys here this is the very
reason I'm doing this video just you
know using this opportunity to mention
that the videos were taken down we've
we've gone and stopped the harm but also
now let's do some good together if we
can collectively come together I'm
trying to raise 500 000 meals for people
in Yemen Afghanistan Palestine Syria and
different parts of the world brothers
and sisters so they can have food to
break the iftar with they don't live
like us when I open my fridge there are
so many things I can choose from brother
and sisters they don't have that luxury
none of us should have one piece of
bread or food going to our stomach
knowing that we haven't contributed
towards it so I'm going to keep this
video very short and simple please
welcome the sisters We've Come Together
against an evil to stop an evil let's
come together again inshallah towards
the good the link is in the description
box below please guys give for the sake
of Allah
even if it's one pound or 50 people and
sisters look at their situation Allah
will ask us about them guys okay
whatever you can give and we can
inshallah feed them for an entire month
man the money we spend on the food that
feeds two people these people feed an
entire family for an entire month may
Allah bless you guys for helping me to
take that video down and may Allah bless
you guys for helping me feed the people
till next time